love you Maxie wonder what the pets we
love do when we move from a human's
behind Despicable Me hi how are you the
secret life of pets you be a good boy
Leonard
I'm Max and I'm the luckiest dog in New
York because of her so long now
today I got big plans I'm gonna sit here
and I'm gonna wait for Katie to come
back oh I miss her so much I have some
big news this is going to be your
brother Chloe Chloe I got a bad
situation
Katie brought home a psychopath from the
pound I don't even have a bed now I'm
sleeping on the floor
like a dog cutie pie oh my gosh what
happened to you
Katie's gonna be worried sick we had a
great thing going I blame myself yeah me
too I blame you a lot
what busted both of you out of here but
from now on you work for me and then
it's me oh just ignore what just
happened
okay this is my city I'll find you a
friend we gotta take this super grep oh
okay the secret route was dead we can
find our way home we are descended from
the mighty wolf
we have raw primal instincts hi how are
you there are moments away from leading
us home isn't home that way
seriously the secret life of the fence
be a good boy Leonard
see you later Chloe
Hey
let's go first oh just ignore what just
happened okay
but you can do the job
come on mags I gotta go so long Mel how
are you how are you the secret life of
pets any plans today yes big big stuff
today Gidget I got big plans I'm gonna
sit here and I'm gonna wait for Katie to
come back well I won't interrupt I've
got a very busy day too
you be a good boy Leonard bye Gidget hey
max hey Gidget any plans today yes
big big stuff today Gidget I got big
plans I'm gonna sit here and I'm gonna
wait for Katie to come back oh that
sounds exciting
well I won't interrupt I've got a very
busy day too
here you go
so long Mel bye sweet pea
see you Gino
by everyone
you be a good boy Leonard
sit stay good boy
seriously